On a un nid qui est à 15 mètres
Il est gros comme une machine à laver
Allé bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui on a une nouveauté
Vous le reconnaissez
Rasta, tu pourrais dire : Bonjour
Voilà ! Vous le connaissez ?
Aujourd'hui j'accueil à Mont-de-Marsan
Baptiste ! - Salut
Quentin
Voilà, Pêcheur de Trésors
Ce que je veux voir, c'est la suite
Je l'ai perdu !
Non !
Elle n'est pas dans l'eau, il est dans le bord
Ils ont une double chance
Je vais vous montrer pourquoi
Bon déjà, ils ont un aimant, ça c'est bien
Vous êtes prêt ?
Je crois qu'il est à plomb
Un pistolet à plomb
Que dire que plus
Ca reste sympa
Bravo Etienne pour l'endroit
A mon avis, ça va être une grande journée
Ouais ça commence bien
A tout de suite
Voilà la découverte
Bien sur on est en compagnie de Etienne
Etienne LGF frelons
Qui nous a invité à Pêcher à l'amant dans son coin
Ca commence bien, calibre 4.5
C'est bien à plomb
Marque Manuarme. Je pense qu'elle est restaurable
Oui je pense
Hâte de tirer dans le garage avec ça
Un pédalier de vélo
Regardes, c'est un mécanisme d'horloge
Ah ouais !
Une vieille horloge
On va descendre sur le bord je pense
Une découverte d'Etienne sur la rive
Ouais, moi j'ai pas besoin d'aimant
J'ai juste eu besoin de mes yeux
Samsung
Affaire à suivre
Il y en a des trucs !
Rasta, tu laisses
On ne pêche pas souvent en rivière, mais il y a des trucs
Justement, c'est tellement peu accessible que ici, personne ne vient pêcher je pense
Là regardez ! Un poste radio
Ah non, c'est peut être pas un poste radio
C'est un scanner on dirait
Il y a écrit : Warning, Security
C'est bizarre
Un scanner
C'est dangereux alors ?
Non, un scanner pour les fréquences
D'accord
C'est original
Je te l'envoie
Non !
Allé, sors nous quelque chose
Ca brille !
Oh Etienne !
Premier bijoux, un bracelet
Il est beau
C'est de l'inox ?
Ouais je pense
C'est sympa
Une plaque de cheminée
Après par contre, je suis obligé de vous mettre devant un nid de frelon
Oui oui, il faut qu'on le fasse aussi
J'en ai déjà attaqué un quand j'étais enfant
J'avais eu une seule piqure, ça va
Il avait mi plein d'habits, les uns sur les autres et il était allé taper avec une barre
Ah quand même !
J'avais mis des lunettes aussi, de piscine
Ah oui quand même
Il était fier de sa bêtise
Sur quoi tu avais fait ça ?
C'était un gros nid qu'il y avait dans une cabane de jardin
Frelons européens ou asiatiques ?
Européens je crois
Il fait rougir l'européen
Oui quand même
En vrai c'était impressionnant
Il a tapé un coup et il a couru après
Tu m'étonnes
Mon petit Rasta
Ca va mon bébé ?
A mon avis, ça a été vidé
Ouais, ils n'ont rien laissé
Même pas des papier d'identité ?
Même pas
Il y a deux ou trois pièces en or mais bon, on s'en fou
Ouais ça tu ne diras pas
Peut être jeté du pont, c'est possible
Oui oui, comme le portable
On va aller voir celle là, si elle est pleine
C'est la même non ?
Non, elle avait une poche à l'avant l'autre
Elle est plus récente
Ouais
Vide encore ?
Dommage
Ils ne nous laissent jamais rien
Pas cool
On va le mettre à la poubelle
Comment ça à la poubelle, je vais le garder
Ah Ah ! Un cubi de rosé
J'ai pêché l'apéro
Bon, Etienne vient d'être appelé pour une alerte frelons
On va le rejoindre, il a des combinaisons pour nous
Je crois qu'il n'y en a pas pour Rasta mais bon, il attendra dans la voiture
C'est pas grave, on le mettra à l'ombre
Et, Hate
Qu'est ce que tu en penses, tu as peur ou pas ?
Des frelons ? Non quand j'étais petit j'attaquais les nids à mains nus
On va voir si ça se passe aussi bien cette fois si
Ca c'est ma vie
C'est pas la pêche à l'aimant
Regardez au dessus
Ah ouais !
Il est costaud
Ah ouais, la belle bête
Il faut faire attention, c'est un insecte très très rapide
Qui peut piquer une dizaine de fois chacun
C'est un cas typique, la personne ne voit pas le nid
Regardes, tous les aller retour qu'il y a
Ouais la personne ne regarde pas en l'air
Elle ne regarde pas en l'air et à mon avis elle rentre en voiture ici
Elle fait le tour et repart par là
Du coup elle n'a rien vu au dessus de sa tête
Mais là il y a un très gros nid
On va traiter ça rapidement
Le seul signe qu'il y a, se sont les déjections un peu partout par terre
D'accord
C'est quel type de frelons là du coup ?
Frelon asiatique : Vespa velutina nigrithorax
Le frelon qui nous mange tout l'écosystème
Le fameux
Deux paires d'ailes décollés, un Rafale
Ca que je vous propose, très simple
On va le faire un peu à la YOLO
Vous allez vous mettre ici et regarder
Moi je vais le faire, j'en ai pour deux minutes
Il ne faut pas se louper
On attend de voir ça
Il faut un aimant c'est ça ?
Très utile, idéal pour l'année 2022
On a pas eu beaucoup de frelons donc on peut faire plein de choses
D'où le fait que j'ai accueilli dans les Landes nos amis chasseurs de trésors
J'en profite d'ailleurs pour remercier nos partenaires Maison de la Détection qui nous ont permis de réaliser cette rencontre avec Etienne
Vous pouvez trouver sur leur site tout le matériel nécessaire pour faire de la pêche à l'aimant ainsi que la détection
Vous avez de super kits adaptés à chaque niveau de pêche à l'aimant mais surtout à différents budgets
Le lien vers le site est affiché en description de la vidéo
Normalement c'est bien organisé que ça dans ma voiture
Non c'est pas vrai
Du coup j'envoie une petite dose d'insecticide
Dans le nid et après on le laisse tranquille
Et on ne se trompe pas de bombonne
D'accord, donc tu ne fais pas tomber le nid
Non, jamais
En plus là c'est sur un lieu de vie
Il faut percer un petit peu sur le côté
Les frelons quand ils vont naitre, ils vont tomber, si ils touchent l'insecticide ils sont morts
Mais ils vont tomber
Est-ce que n'importe qui peut acheter cet insecticide ?
Pas du tout
Ah voilà, c'est surpuissant
C'est un biocide
Petit compresseur, ça monte à 6 bar
6 bars ça fait 6 fois le volume
Donc à la main ça va être compliqué si vous voulez essayer
Je vous laisserez une pompette si vous voulez
On a eu notre dose avec le treuil tout à l'heure
On a pus noter qu'il y en a un seul de vous deux qui a utilisé le treuil
Mais je ne dis rien, je ne veux pas foutre la merde
C'est normal, c'est celui qui ne se baigne pas qui utilise le treuil
ça reste un insecticide mais ce n'est pas super polluant
Ah ouais d'accord
Ils sont de plus en plus respectueux de l'environnement et ça c'est bien
Tu es sûr du chemin emprunté par les frelons là ?
Ne restez pas en plein passage, allez là sur le côté
La douche n'était pas nécessaire
Alors ne t'inquiètes pas
C'est moi qui le ferme et c'est moi qui te l'ouvre
Rasta aime bien ta tenue
C'est un chien d'apiculteur
Mais non c'est pas une tenue d'apiculteur
Donc là en fait
Tu vas penser à ouvrir le robinet au dernier moment
Ok
Ensuite tu vas poser ça sur le nid
Et au moment ou tu poses sur le nid, "pchit", un petit coup
Un tout petit coup d'accord ?
Mais bien dans le nid
Et tu restes là pour regarder comment ça se passe
Fais gaffe à toi quand même Quentin
Vas y vas y
C'est bon là
Bien joué
Impact du frelon sur la caméra *
Oh il y en a une qui a tapé dans la go pro !
je te jure !
C'est normal
Ils détestent les Go Pro
C'est magique
Et non pas les frelons, toi t'es trop petit
Non il est trop gros, viens
Nous n'avons pas de tenue pour toi Rasta
Allez voilà
ça s'active au bord
Nouvelle mission
Ah ouais il est énorme en plus
Ce n'est pas moi qui l'ai trouvé, ce sont les voisins
Oui c'est normal ça
Là on va mettre la Go Pro sur la perche
Ah ouais c'est bien ça
Après si tu veux on peut faire autrement
Si vous voulez que j'y monte, j'y monte moi
Ahaha
C'est ce que j'allais dire, un des deux est habitué là mais bon
Maintenant il faudrait envoyer l'autre
Après  ça c'est comme une échelle, tu peux y monter
sans problème
Non mais attendez, il va pas monter comme ça
Non non en vrai ça ne sert à rien
Il est bien vivant le nid
Il y en a plein là
Je vais le couper le pin
Ah bah voilà
Si en plus vous n'aimez pas votre pin, effectivement c'est le mieux
Il faut le descendre comme ça les frelons seront moins haut
En fait là tu as deux solutions
Ouais
Tu as le PIPE, c'est le fusil insecticide
C'est très marrant
Mais ça coûte super chère, et voilà ...
Et après tu as la perche
D'accord
Là en l'occurrence la perche c'est le mieux
Elle fait 30 mètres tu as dis ?
Il n'y a pas 30 mètres
Non mais moi je peux monter jusqu'à 30 mètres
Bon là le procédé est simple, on a un nid à 15 mètres
Il est gros comme une machine à laver
T'as un être super agressif à tes pieds
Tu connais, c'est un chien
Donc là on va utiliser cet engin pour monter dans le nid
Parce que on en avait un courageux là
Il était prêt à escalader
Mais quand je lui ai expliqué qu'on pouvait le faire avec la perche, il a accepté
Donc on vous met la Go Pro là haut
Et vous allez tout voir, c'est Nikel
Voilà on approche du nid
Maintenant ce qui est important c'est de lever le pied
Allez y !
Là tu lèves le pied et op
Tu peux envoyer
C'est impressionnant
Alors la Go Pro, elle est dangereuse ?
Ah oui regarde son état
Elle est encore allumée en tout cas
Elle est repeinte tout en blanc
Purée ouais ils l'ont attaquée de partout
La caméra est vraiment devenue opaque
Tout ça c'est eux ?
Il y en a encore
Là ça va tourner autour pendant une bonne heure
Et ça pue aussi, pourquoi ?
C'est le venin
Un mélange d'urine et de venin
Ah ok
Donc oui le frelon vous a pissé dessus
Super
ça tu nous l'a dis qu'après
Ah oui ça tourne encore
En fait il y a des phéromones d'attaque sur la Go pro
Ah ouais
On va la rincer un peu avant de retourner pêcher avec
Bon là on a quelque chose de très lourd, on a sorti le treuil 2 tonnes
On va voir
Ils n'ont pas voulu jouer, moi à l'origine j'ai dis qu'on allait tirer avec le 4x4
Parce que ça tire tout ça, mais ils m'ont dit que l'aimant pouvait être catapulté
Ton treuil est en train de rendre l'âme
Comment ça va se terminer, l'objet sort ou le 4x4 tombe à l'eau ?
Vous préférez voire quel scénario en vidéo ?
Je pense que le 4x4 qui fini là bas c'est mieux
Il y a moyen d'avoir du buzz
Tu sais ce que c'est ça ?
C'est quoi ça ?
C'est une cuisinière
Tu penses ?
C'est cuisinière en fonte
Une cuisinière en fonte dans l'eau
Cet anneau il m'intéresse
Parce que j'ai une cuisinière à bois
Ca peut expliquer le poids
C'est certain
Treuil à l'eau
Attend mais c'est quoi ça ?
C'est pas notre corde !
Il y a un grappin et un aimant
On est pas les premiers à avoir essayé
Forcément ça, a cassé aussi
La mission c'est de réussir à sortir ça
C'est ça
Si vous reconnaissez votre grappin et votre aimant
Je pense que je vais les offrir à Etienne parce qu'il débute et a besoin de matériel solide
Merci
C'est le format miniature
C'est quoi cet aimant ?
C'est qui, qui fait ça ?
C'est Wish
On peut le mettre sur le frigidaire
Avec un photo
Mine de rien, le grappin il va bien
Il est trop léger
Tu veux que je te montre les grappins que m'a donné Maison de la Détection ?
Le classique, déjà plus gros
Il n'a pas encore servi
Bon, on tire ?
On va tirer ouais
Là, ça ne rigole plus
Regardez ce qu'on a trouvé, c'est bizarre
Rasta c'est fait des copains
Rasta ! Qu'est ce que c'est ça ?
C'est quoi ce petit truc qui t'attaque ?
Si vous savez, dites en commentaire, je pense que c'était sur le gros objet
On va voir
Oula, ça a bien bullé
Tu l'as encore ?
Ouais ouais
Ca avait l'air gros
Ah, quand même quelque chose
Un morceau de la cuisinière
On a trouvé cuisinière à bois
J'ai quelque chose moi aussi !
Nul
C'est en fer forgé
Il a une drôle de forme
C'est pour faire des trous dans le bois
D'accord
Tu rajoute un manche et tu tourne
Sympa. - C'est un vieil outil
Regardes !
Une pelle
Elle est parfaite
Voilà
Une pelle fonctionnelle
C'est au moins la 5ème qu'on trouve, un classique
La pelle c'est un classique
Je ne sais pas comment ils font tomber leurs pelle mais bon
C'est cool
Je prend
Vu qu'on est en road trip, je pense que l'on va te l'offrir
Tu en auras plus besoin que nous
Tu as coincé les deux aimants ?
Le mec il vient de me rentrer carrément dans le pneu
Je le regardai faire
Il n'est pas doué
Il n'arrive pas à faire le créneau
Il est embêté et il m'est carrément rentré dans le pneu. C'est pas grave c'est que le pneu
Je crois que c'est bon
Il a réussi
Il a réussi son créneau et nous on a réussi à sortir l'aimant
Double réussite
Dans cet épisode, Etienne nous a amené chasser du frelon asiatique
Nous l'avons amené pêcher un pistolet un plomb
Si cette vidéo vous a plut, dites le nous en commentaire
On va chasser du frelon européen et tenter de pêcher quelque chose d'encore mieux